All right. Shuli Gilutz,
thank you so much for joining me.
Great to be here or there. Somewhere.
Who knows anymore.
Shuli, what does it mean to be an expert
on Children’s User Experience in digital?
What does that mean?
It's a great question.
Because I don't know if the word digital
like how that expertise or experience.
But generally what we look at is how
to design environment deal,
environment interactive,
environments for kids.
Which are [--]
So, [--] design.
It started out with a more cognitive focus
in terms of learning and a tech gen.
But today we talk about social, relevant
and emotional
and all these other challenges
that we have in designing.
Okay. So, when you talk about children,
what demographic are you an expert on?
What demographic are we talking about?
So, children zero to 18
that's the legal boundaries.
Even though research today talks about
childhood ending in around 25.
So, I'm still a kid. Great. Finally.
I have a confirmation
that I can be a kid again.
Wonderful.
There you are. But legally 18.
I guess it depends on different countries.
Some countries legal age
for different things
There are areas in US 21 for some things.
But legally zeros to 18.
So, you know it's such a confusing time.
And it's such a fascinating time
to think about this.
Because I'm looking at all this
social media apps that are rising.
And it's incredible to see how,
I'm 24. I consider myself a child still.
And a very young user.
Yet I use Facebook primarily
than Instagram.
I don’t really know what Tiktok is.
But I heard that I'm supposed to be there.
But it's crazy. Because already I feel
illiterate when it comes to the usage
of how young people use social media
and interact with it overall.
So, tell me a little bit about
what is the study that you're doing?
And what are the differences between
the way that young people
use these things
versus the older generations?
Like myself.
So, exactly that's a great question.
Because you would not be considered
an old generation. You're a millennial.
I mean you're the younger generation.
Right? But what we see now is fascinating.
I've been in this field for about 20 years.
And we've always divided up kids
to five, eight years. Right?
So, you have your babies. Your toddlers.
Early elementary. Tweens and teens.
You think that that would be enough.
But apparently, it's not.
Because it turns out that every five years
there's this jump in technology.
And what happens is
It's not that the children become smarter.
Evolution doesn’t happen over five years.
It happens over millions of years.
So what the differences is,
that when they're born with
certain technologies as a baseline,
They start from there.
And that's what the minimum
they expect everything
to work in a certain way.
So, you can even see what kids today
like I teach children one is 13
and one is almost 10.
So, my 13 years old, when he searches
goes primarily to tech space search,
YouTube, other sites.
My 10-year-old. When she was very young.
When she was four, YouTube Kids came out.
And I showed it to her.
And it has voice search.
So, she would go, "Elsa."
And it would play Let It Go whatever.
She uses voice search today.
She could write. She could do anything.
It just open a gap.
And he never use voice search.
Why would he use voice search.
He could type.
But he's 13. So, we see already those
a few years have very different behaviors.
And we see that with boys a lot today.
Kids growing up with Alexa at home,
and Google home and Siri
They treat voice very naturally.
While kids who are just a few years older
and 20-year olds like yourself,
are like, "Okay. Maybe I'll use Siri here.
Maybe I'll use voice there.
But younger kid do it. It's just so natural to them.
Because they was always there.
Like their Legos and like their other books.
It was even there before they were able
to read and write, they were able to speak
and therefore if that's an option
on YouTube Kids then that becomes
their default way.
Exactly. And they're just used to it.
And when adults use it, they are like
Okay. What should I say?
What's the command?
What's the right thing to do?
yeah. I think that's fascinating.
Because it must been already few years.
My father is in Google and I've seen him
talk to his Google assistant
and I hate voice.
I can’t voice it.
I don't do the right command.
My phone doesn’t understand me.
I feel so old when it comes to this.
So, now I'm thinking that he's a revolutionary.
That in his great age and he's been
using it for years. But it makes sense
that the new generations,
that's where they are gonna be adapted to.
So, this is where we should capitalize.
So, what else?
What other differences we have?
Well I have to say though,
in defense of your father,
this is not a typical in his generation
I would say.
But actually voice is very big
with the older generation. Older adults.
Because it, again, allows them
to do things that maybe is harder
for them in other ways.
So, they are actually
early adapters in that area.
Which is really interesting.
I mean there are a lot of
[--]
and others.
But voice is very big. And in many ways.
I have this colleague who talks about
designing for older adults.
And a lot of times we find ourselves
together in conferences.
Me talking about kids.
And him talking about adults.
Oh, that's awesome.
Oh, that is so cool. Yeah.
Very interesting.
But the thing about kids is that
they're not afraid.
So, that's why kids are such great learners.
They take a phone and say,
"Hmn, what will happen if I put this
in the toilet? That was cool."
And the parents are like, "Aaahh."
And they put it in.
And they have to put it
in rights or whatever.
Just so you know, rights.
But they're curious.
And they try everything.
So, when you try everything,
You figure that.
That's how you learn the best.
When you are like,
Oh my God, what will I press?
What do I do?
Then you don't learn anything.
Then it's much slower.
It's not that they're smarter.
It's just they're more open.
They're not afraid.
They don't care that it cost so much.
That's why they're great learners.
Especially in technology.
And also the fact that they're not,
especially the younger kids
they're not really aware to
what we mean by technology.
If you talk to young children, you ask them,
You know, what's your favorite technology?
They will be like,
The refrigerator. The car.
Technology's everywhere. Right?
The distinction between digital,
that's why I said UX digital,
and a non-digital
is a very old distinction.
It's an adult thing.
Because you work in high tech.
Whatever that means.
They don't care you're creating stuff.
For fun, for game, for learning, for play.
And they don't care if Lego has center
or doesn’t have centers. Or a fun game.
Yeah. That's what they care about.
So, these distinctions are very like
top down and very adult
and not relevant to their lives.
They are looking at the final product.
And for UX,
it's like what's the experience here?
Is it a great learning experience?
Is it a fun experience?
Is it motivating?
Do they wanna play it more?
They don’t care if it has centers, or digital.
Either they are in it or not.
Right. So, you're teaching at Shenkar
in Tel Aviv University.
And what do you focusing on?
And what do entrepreneurs
today who are building products
that are going to be used by kids
or other demographics?
Is this something that they need to
keep in mind and really understand
the different user experiences?
Is there a really clear distinction?
Yeah. I think that's two different things.
I think students at Tel Aviv University
and Shenkar, they're very interested in this.
They see what's happening around them.
And they can tell the difference.
They don't really know
how to engage at it exactly.
You notice people are into Minecraft.
There's Fortnite.
These days there's Tiktok.
Or Snapchat. Like, what's going on?
And it's fine. It's exciting.
But I think, the important thing for an
entrepreneur is really to understand
that there's a variety of kids.
I've worked in so many companies
that come and say,
"My kids, they love reading on an iPad."
So, blah blah blah blah blah
I'm just, "Okay."
Let's see what their age really.
Do you know how many kids
with developmentally appropriate?
So that all these myths that we really
have to de-use user research too.
But like with any other UX
and any other product,
to tease them apart.
there are a lot of myths
about kids and technology.
And unfortunately,
the biggest one is screen time.
Everybody is afraid of screen time.
Especially in the valley.
And I think it's really interesting because
there is no such thing as screen time.
If you look at,
I gave my kids 20 minutes
of screen time today.
What does that mean?
That they are watching 20 minutes
of Sesame Street?
National Geographic? Or porn?
Were they watching reality TV?
Or sports? Was it Dora?
What does that even mean?
It's like you would never,
you know in a book or any other game.
It's about the content.
And then the context.
What are the alternatives?
Now, 20 minutes of screen time
can mean talking to grandma.
Because you can’t go and visit her.
Is that being bad?
Right.
So, it's really about the content.
The context, and the alternative. Right?
And also the specific child.
What's the age group?
What are their capabilities?
What do they need in their lives?
So, I think by boxing in on the screen time,
We're really doing a disservice for our kids.
And also, were not looking at ourselves.
Because as the adult around the kid,
we're on this thing all the time.
Not 20 minutes. Not 20 hours.
But 24 hours 24/7.
There's so many service to show that
So, these kids are growing up
in a very different childhood.
than you grew up.
And that I grew up in for sure.
Where everybody is connected
all the time.
They wanna be like the adults
around them.
So, it's not fair to judge them and say
"Oh, when I was a kid,
we use to play outside all the time."
Right. Because you didn’t have this
super computer library in your pocket
all the time and neither did your parents.
or your siblings, or your friends,
and everybody else.
Very different childhood especially 2020.
This acceleration is amazing. Right.
I mean amazing in the sense
that it's remarkable. I don't know if its
I don’t know what's going to be on kids
But one of the things that
I’m curious about,
So, we talked about this trend that
kids are much more into experimentation
and as the generations grow older,
the will or the excitement
about experimentation decreases or
there's an increase in anxiety or fear.
Are there other key differences
that you've noticed
between the usage of kids
versus the usage of adults?
And some things that product designers
or entrepreneurs can keep in mind
as they're designing their products
for the different demographics?
Yes. Definitely.
So, number one I think
the most important one is motivation.
So, when you're designing a product
for adult,
your motivations are a lot of times.
you totally you wanna be efficient,
you want to get in the time on task.
Just to measure,
you check your ROI according to
how much time you saving,
how much money you're saving
With kids, it's not just the case.
Again, it depends on the age group,
the content and the context.
But a lot of times, kids are using
technology for fun, for entertainment
for learning.
They will spend an hour watching
something that you think is not a value
but for them it's huge.
And if you really wanna empower them,
and give them the ability to create
like drawings, like they're drawing a data
if they're creating stop-motion animation
or they're creating video games.
That they're programming.
That will take hours.
So, it's not about efficiency
which is very important.
It's a very different thing
when you're doing UX for adults.
Efficiency is a very big thing.
So, motivations, intrinsic motivations,
things that I'm passionate about.
While adults a lot of times have
external motivations. Things for work.
It changes the ability.
There's a modification a few years ago
things that's going down a bit
because people don’t understand that
once you are doing things for badges and
leaderboards and stars.
That becomes the motivation and
you'll forget about
what you're actually loving to do.
So, even in places like Khan academy
and places that have really
kind of noble way to treat education
or doing great things.
They've lowered the gamification of it.
So, the focus is still the content.
So, gamification works.
No doubt about it. It works.
It just changes the focus
from the content.
for different people
who does different things.
Interesting. But I'd love to say that
I was looking for motivation to finish
the course on Khan Academy all back
when I was in high school.
And I was doing self-study
for advance math.
And decide that I had those badges.
And I had that streak.
All of sudden it kept me from
exiting a video because I knew that if
I just listen to the last two minutes
which are always important because
that's where you usually
have the summary
but we think,
every kid thinks
he's the smartest kid in the world.
So, I think I don’t need to listen
to this summary. I got it.
But I wouldn’t have received my
extra 90 tokens if I didn’t stay on.
So, I stayed on and I'm very thankful
that I did that.
Shuli, talk to me a little bit
about your work.
What does it mean to be
an expert on user experience for kids?
Do you work with startups?
Do you teach? How does it work?
Okay. So, I'm a few different bits
to my work.
I'm very into disciplinarian.
I’ve got one feet in academia
one feet in the industry.
I don’t really fit anywhere.
But I really enjoy it.
Because I love theory.
And I love research.
And I love thinking about products
that just benefit kids.
And without have to thinking
about marketing sales
and all of that stuff.
However, I like doing things
in the real world.
I would actually teach kids too.
So, trying to do both.
I consult companies who develop
products for kids.
This could be AR, VR.
And apps like digital TV apps.
And now I'm working with the company
that's building an online platform
for education.
So, when they are doing
these products we the folio X process.
So, we think about who are stakeholders?
Who are the users?
Where are they pinpointing the lights
the journey.
But we do add the unique factors
of designing for kids and for families.
Which go together with designing
for children’s rights.
Which is another organization
I'm a part of. And I'm thinking about
what this affords them?
What this really gives them?
More than only what they need.
Because need is again, it's very adult word.
are main point
that means you have a goal
and you have an efficiency and so forth.
And there are also
some legal considerations
for us to consider
data, privacy, security.
when you're designing for kids.
Which are slightly different.
Again, depending on the
different age groups.
When you said the word children’s rights
then immediately my thought was,
how do you design responsibly for kids?
not just in terms of the legal aspect
on the data and privacy.
But also in terms of,
it's much easier I think to,
I'm assuming to get a kid addicted to
something than it is
to get an adult addicted.
Because the adult has those firewalls.
Those internal firewalls that tell them,
I'm actually spending too much time here
or I'm not doing the right thing.
A kid may not have that.
So, what is responsibility here
in terms of understanding
how to design responsibly for kids?
So, ethics are big.
So, you hit the point.
Adult have that or not.
But we can’t. They're adults.
They can do whatever they want.
We do have legal protection.
For different things.
from gamblings to other things.
But we know that there are way
to introduce dark UX
to create addictions and so forth.
Now, for kids that's worst.
I like that term. Dark UX.
Dark UX. There you go.
Look it up. You'll find creepy stuff.
But for kids, especially in my kids,
they don’t even know
that some things are odds.
I have this conversation with my son
a few years ago.
When one of his favorite youtubers
was showing in some thing
with Lego or Minecrafter.
And then I told him,
"Well you know he get paid for that."
He looked at me and said,
"What?"
And I said, "Yeah."
"You know they're promoting."
And I said,
"You know I like this youtuber."
"I really do. He's awesome."
"He picks really good products."
"I like the way he dress up."
"That's why I let you watch him."
"But you should know that Lego
paid him to go to Legoland
to get the stuff."
He started crying and he's like,
"How can you say that?"
"This is just what he love."
So, we have now,
of course, my kids,
they're involve in my career.
So, they know what’s going on.
But a lot of kids don’t.
They believe that these influencers
are passionate about their stuff.
Now, some of the stuff that
youtubers pull are awesome.
A lot of environmental stuff,
A lot of great stuff.
But they are promoters
of all kinds of efforts
And there's no way,
In TV, in linear TV there used to be
We'll be back after these messages.
Right? When we were watching a show
And you were going to commercials.
That was a way to tell children
Okay, the cartoons you're seeing now
are ads.
The cartoons you saw before are content.
That's how they distinguish it.
So, they have the same characters.
Spiderman’s here and spiderman there.
It’s the same.
In internet, in digital,
we don’t have that linear
So, we have to be very responsible.
There a lot going on in terms of ads
and kids’ apps, and page stuff
and different models for it.
But yeah, you have to be aware
of these things and think about it.
and think about what kind of experience
you want to create for your users.
Ethically not only legally.
I think two things came to mind
when you were giving that example
of my beautiful niece
whose now five years old.
But this is already relevant
from when she was three.
That she would watch these
unboxing videos on YouTube
And when I saw that,
I thought it was the
most ridiculous thing.
I couldn’t believe that we're watching
another kid unbox a toy now.
And then I looked at how many
viewers in it. It had a billion views.
It was one of the most
popular videos on YouTube.
And then every time,
On YouTube there was the ads
that come up in the middle.
She would go furious.
She was yelling, "I don’t understand."
"How do I exit out of this?"
"How do I skip?"
And I thought it was just incredible.
Because I grew up,
In Saturday morning I go to the TV,
And I watch my cartoons
And I wait. And I wait for the cartoons
And whatever happens, happens.
Right. But that's a great point.
Because first of all the cartoon,
they don’t get the whole
why do we have to wait?
And why do we have to watch?
But the adults don’t get it either.
So, they're good.
They're get along and everything.
But the thing about the unboxing
and there's a lot written about that
and it's really cool.
So, if you think about clay patterns.
Clay patterns don’t change across media.
But if you think about peek-a-boo. Right?
It's the same thing. It's unboxing.
So, you just walk in, "Wow. Surprise."
And then another one.
"Wow. I wonder what's gonna be
in there now. So, it's so exciting."
We call it unboxing because
we have no clue what's going on there.
But for them it's just a surprise show.
After surprise. After surprise.
Which is really cool.
You know how when kids get gifts?
They save that.
The box parts is the best part.
They play the cardboard.
That's it. Over and over again.
It's amazing.
Wow. Perfect.
That is so so cool.
Are there different things
that we should be worried about?
with the way that generations are moving
and interacting with technology.
Should I be worried about
some of the things that my niece
is going to experience different
from the way I will
whether in terms of social interactions,
or personal fulfillment.
or emotional intelligence.
Oh yeah. But it's hard to say what.
So, I think the problem with that is that
a lot of parents today
don’t know what their kids are doing.
They can’t deal with it.
Parenting is hard. You're a parent.
Your kids are doing stuff you haven’t
done when you were a kid.
They're not watching Saturday
morning cartoons anymore.
Maybe they are but they are doing
definitely another thing.
And so, you have to learn
what they are doing.
What's right and wrong.
What's going on.
And it's really really difficult.
So, why are parents obsessed?
Do whatever you need to do.
Let me know if I have to buy something.
And that's the big problem now.
Because you would never let your kid
just go around the street
and go to people you don’t know.
And there could be things that are not
for them are dangerous.
Or even if you let them play like
I have a mom I talk about Fortnite and
how I thought it was actually
a pretty cool game for tweens.
And she was so angry and she said
"You know my kid you should see him."
"He plays eight hours of Fortnite."
"He's like a zombie."
And I'm like,
Why is he playing eight hours of Fortnite?
One hour. Two hours.
With his friends that's awesome.
It's a game that has diversity.
You play with groups.
you're assigned gender, ethnicity,
random. There's no blood.
There's sweet little cute animals.
There's dances.
Eight hours? Like eight hours?
So, and I think,
Because she's like, Ah, yes.
He's playing with his friends.
So, I think the problem for the kid
is not the technology per se.
But the problem with the parents
are kind of stuck. They don’t know.
They don’t know enough about
when to say yes, when to say no.
They have to sit down
and play with their kids.
They have to know what Fortnite really is.
What Minecraft really is.
And then they’ll know how to parent it.
Like what they do with anything else.
There’s no other way.
Because it keeps changing.
Its like you said about Tiktok.
Today is Tiktok.
Three years ago is Snapchat.
Two years ago something else.
It's gonna be something else soon.
Because too many adults are in Tiktok.
The teens are gonna leave.
They don’t want those there.
Really, adults are going to Tiktok?
Oh yeah. All these moms are trying
to be cool.
And all these companies are trying to
use Tiktok as a platform
for products of course.
So, the minute that happened,
You know it's gonna shift soon
in some way.
But the thing is that,
parents to know.
So, my advice would be
just sit down and play.
Don’t read articles whatever.
Just sit down and play with your kids.
Just see what's going on.
What do they do.
They'll love.
They wanna talk to you about these things.
Fascinating.
And if there’s a point where they don’t.
Where they’re teens already.
That's difficult. But still be there with them.
Just show them you care.
Show them that you're into that.
Just don’t dismiss it all as screen time.
Oh c'mon, I don’t understand about that.
Then you're just creating a bigger gap.
And its harder to parent them.
100%. Shuli, 20 minutes go by
so so fast. But I have to ask you the most
important question. Three words that
best describe you.
Okay. One I guess it would be
Interdisciplinary. Because I don’t know
what I do.
The other one would be Curious.
I'm always interested in what’s going on.
And the last one would be an Optimist.
Because I really believe it's all good.
Wow. Most people when they talk
about this the way the kids are
interacting with technology
and the addiction, they're very,
they're on the opposite spectrum
of optimism.
because they haven’t talk to kids.
That's what I love about what I do.
I get to sit and talk to them,
and play with them,
and they’re the best.
That's amazing. Shuli, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
Toda. Stay safe and stay healthy.
Thanks. Bye. Take care.